and my opponent is saying that the
stream is muted perfect let's try the
French exchange no all right we're gonna
go with this the advance variation I'm
gonna look to get rid of my LightSquared
Bishop however I'm not used to seeing
Bishop d3 here I'm used to seeing first
something like this as soon as I played
c5 actually after Knight f3 I could have
been considering captures I was getting
too caught up in the routine however
okay
well what's wrong with just capturing
now hmm maybe nothing I'm just gonna let
it sit stay put the main idea is get rid
of the bad man and he's the bad man okay
so my opponent is having none of it he
is saying you know what I don't want to
deal with you getting rid of your
LightSquared Bishop that is understood
however now b4 is weakened
I'm thinking about a six first is my
queen really want to be dislodged hmm
candidate moves pawn takes a 6c for what
I really want to do that probably none
of them um I'm investing a lot of time
here
now let's take break down the center and
you know it if my queen is kicked I'm
gonna drop back to c7 let's get my night
out I've given up on this idea of
getting rid of my light-square bishop at
this point so by ripping out this pond
or take taking out the base of White's
pawn structure he's now going to be
something I could put pressure on I
think let's see I might want to
voluntarily go back yeah let's go let's
go back here first I'm I'm anticipating
Knight b3 or that okay let's see what's
going to be done about this pawn here
and if I play Bishop b4
this night is actually quite annoying so
let me do this night b4 I was talking
about this being a weakness if I did
Bishop b4 Bishop d2 he's considered my
good Bishop but I don't know if I would
give so much weight to the good bad
bishop positions I also have maybe this
move available Knight f4 hmm maybe there
is a purpose in getting rid of the dark
square bishop let's try this they gonna
come off c3 c3 is played on up a clear
punt I don't I won't have any worries
about watching over d4 anymore
and these pawns will then be split of an
isolated sea pond and a pond and maybe I
could post up on the C file somewhere so
a time deficit I don't have anything
better than to recapture I don't know if
I'm so quick to read to castle and one
thing I have to be careful of is Knight
g3 to h5 to put pressure on g7 my idea
here is to maybe capture the bishop and
then maybe there won't be enough defense
on e5 so I think I do well to just take
first and now where does my dark square
Bishop belong I wonder about that I kind
of like it keeping a close eye on this
Square still so yeah let me do that
there might be some pawn push one day I
should probably castle my dark squares
are a bit sensitive but is there
anything better
that's so sure about that hmm I might
want to do this pawn push even even if I
give the pawn back okay this is starting
to scare me
it's definitely starting to scare me
okay what about pawn push just a trade
no I don't like that my light square
bishop is a big dummy less than two
minutes you know what I'm thinking about
doing
um this I'm thinking about doing this
that was fantastic that there's more
instructional value in that line right
there than any other what are you
thinking about doing would you tell me
this I'm thinking about doing this
everybody gets a ton out of that line
right there okay my idea is to say you
know what my Knights are well Knights
generally are quite tricky but sometimes
they are expendable in fact in fact what
what am I getting at here I'm getting at
that sometimes getting to pawns for the
knight can still be pretty good
compensation especially when things
become more simplified and I see that
take shape quite a bit actually when I'm
playing against the computer I'm in big
trouble
I'm in very big trouble yeah that's the
move that scares me because now what am
I gonna do
I got a do have five cuz I have after
babysit this pawn oh man
big trouble big trouble
this is clearly this was not this was
not calculated and if Queen here I think
I have to bring my Bishop back to d8
well I hope hopefully this works out I'm
into 22 I have to keep up the pressure
my queen is getting hit rook takes Queen
pawn takes Queen and then I'm on the
rook and then and then maybe there's
this this is what I was hoping to get so
as it stands right now am i what do I
have one two three four one two three
four three pawns for the night very
interesting game so far
Queen g5 I'm pretty sure I'm locked in
okay I gotta take that Queen I'm on the
rook and I think I want to kick this
knight or maybe even push forward in the
center or maybe I could do this if the
Brook doesn't come back to defend the
bishop maybe I have this move oh that's
scary town I was not expecting that pawn
push bishop sack my king is gonna run
away hopefully well maybe I should have
considered rook here instead if rook
takes pawn pawn push I'm hitting the
rook and then I could slam the door on
the bishop with e4 and I'll still be
looking to d4 did what this really work
Bishop takes pawn takes rook takes King
here rook check King here I don't see
the follow-up at that point my king is
there to watch over the bishop well
we're gonna have that art Lee
let's see rook check I'm locked into
this move rook g7 King e 8 it's an only
move I can't allow the night to get here
oh I was just missed oh man I had that
square covered otherwise they would have
got my bishop if I didn't have that okay
I could just drop all the way back but
I'm gonna challenge the rook and if
there's a check I'll block I have this
square covered by my knight I want to
just get rid of the dark square Bishop
right now okay let's go here and when
the rook moves my my rook is hit let me
counter-attack
so I'm up two pieces now and this guy's
pinned and I'm gonna be winning another
piece soon King f7 about even on time
and I just want to trade trade trade
some more keep everything connected grab
this pawn you have this pond and in
march
keep marching although I could keep
marching keep pushing I could push if
rook here and then finally get my rook
it's probably gonna do that as a pre
move okay good game that got wild oh man
I don't know if that was working out for
me let's go back let's flip this game
flip the board so I should have been
considering capturing right away but
okay I liked retaining my flexibility I
was I think rattling off the different
candidate moves that I had here I liked
retaining this bronze flexibility
because in some cases I might want to
push c4 but I have to be quite careful
about doing that because I released the
pressure on white center and then Y
could try to get in this f5 break that
would be the ideal break as soon as
there's less pressure pressure on d4 the
f5 break white you look into so white
foils my plan of trying to get rid of my
bad bishop for their good Bishop with
Bishop b5 I break at the base point and
now I'm attacking a5 next that's my plan
from there but white is there to defend
and maybe I should have actually
considered instead of instead of rook c8
maybe I should have done this first the
bishop would have to block if the rook
moves then this falls so bishop here
pawn push would be no good at that point
Bishop b4 might have been improving
bishop before Bishop blocked bishop
takes this knight recaptures and then
white has to still go back to f1 spend a
move to get back to f1 to get to f3 and
then maybe I could jump into this square
maybe that's an improvement cuz things
surely got very scary right here this
Knight is I mean he's looking to rip the
heart over heart out of my pawn
structure on the Kings side or maybe
even jump in to f6 and somehow get a
queen to h6 look from looking for mate
on g7
that's why I felt it necessary to kind
of go for this if just queen takes okay
I end up getting this at the end and I'm
up what would it be one two three three
pawns for the three pawns for the knight
interesting in balance I think I would
be doing alright in that position but
queen g4 I did not calculate but
fortunately I have this I think which is
working out again if Queen g5 I think I
have to throw my bishop back not a movie
I want to have to make but yeah I think
I was locked into that variation for
sure so Queen trade and then I don't
think that this is good enough because
because there's only two attackers and I
have plenty of defenders he's well I
guess you could say there's a third
attacker but I should have enough
defense Knight f6 is a mistake I don't
know if there's really anything else
seems like it's going to be defendable
from here but okay good game a GM chess